So across the pond, spaz
is short for spastic.
The spaz that I grew up with as a
teenager in the 90 seconds, fans
know. Do you want to by being like a
total laundry spaz?
He's a spazz.
Where it meant that you were, like, maybe a little bit
random. It could even be a term of
endearment.
That is
not the same as the space that's
used in African-American vernacular
English, where it basically means
that you're about to fight somebody.
So we don't use that term in the US
the way that they do in
the UK, which is where
this shortening to spaz has become
the equivalent of a slur.
Probably the closest analog
in American English is like
retard. It carries that type
of weight.
In early summer 2022, Lizzo
was called out by an Australian
activist for using the word spaz
and her new song Girlzz.
Lizzo made sure to emphasize that
she herself as a fat black woman
in America, had experienced
oppression and language
based oppression.
She did sort of remind
this activist from Australia
which side her progressive bread
was buttered on.
I've had many hurtful words used
against me, so I understand the
power words can have, Lizzo
said in a statement posted to
Instagram.
I'm proud to say there's a new
version of Girlzz with the lyric
change. Hold my bag.
Do you see the shit?
Hold me back.
Just seven weeks later, Beyoncé
operated for using a similar phrase,
"spazzing on that ass,"
in her song Heated.
Fans never heard from Beyoncé
herself because Lizzo sort of primed
to pump for her.
Beyoncé didn't, I think, really have
much of a choice to be responsive
in the way that she was.
Two major artists
altered the lyrics to their songs.
They arrest the word spaz
in post-production after the album's
already been released, after
activists from Australia
and other locations across the pond
espouses a much worse word
than it is in the US, objected
and said that it was ablest.
This is a rapidly advancing new
frontier for the suppression of free
speech and artistic expression,
Rosenfield writes in a new article
for Reason magazine.
Stop spazzing out about Spaz.
It's something beyond burning books,
something beyond destruction.
It's stories and songs and films
cut apart and written over
leaving no trace and no remnant
of what ever used to be.
It wasn't unheard of
for an artist to alter their lyrics
after the fact. You could expect
them to respond to you that they
were sort of a moral authority.
This idea that you needed to be able
to look up to artists not just
because you enjoyed the art they
made, but because they were supposed
to represent some kind of a role
model to you
as the listener.
They're supposed to reflect your
values, you know, morally,
politically, etc..
I think that people
got not just used
to, but maybe a little bit drunk
on the realization that
if they made enough noise,
they could kind of emotionally
blackmail artists
who were concerned with reputation
management into
doing their bidding.
On the one hand, people who
like music or like
books, who like to consume
culture, and on the other hand,
you have people who want
to control culture, who want to
go back to the artist and say, I
don't like what you did here.
It offends me. Change it.
There is virtually no overlap
between these two groups.
They have completely separate sets
of motivations, completely separate
things that they're trying to
achieve when they engage with a
given work.
Artists are left at the nexus
of this where they want to be
creating work for the former people,
people who genuinely like art,
but they are subject
to the whims and
the punishments, the consequences
meted out by the latter group.
And I don't think that
this is a great environment in
which to be trying to
create much of anything, let alone
create it bravely.
Swift's new video for her song
Anti-Hero is facing controversy
over a song where she steps
on a scale that reads fat.
Critics are saying she's promoting
so-called fatphobia, but her
supporters are pointing out how
she has always been open about her
struggle with her own eating
disorders. And the video reflects
what she sees, not what
you see her seeing.
Taylor Swift chose to alter the
scene in her music video, where she
is standing on a scale that reads
fat to her, just simply
staring at her disruptive and
disapproving doppelganger.
This actually strikes me as maybe
the most tragic example of
this happening on a contemporary
landscape, because here
is a case of not just
a word being used in a context
by one person where another person
says, Well, in our culture, that's
offensive. This is a woman talking
about her own personal history,
revealing something that is painful
about herself and exploring that
through her art and the idea that
she is going to be scolded.
And made to change
her work because
other people didn't like the way
that she was negotiating her own
pain in her artwork.
That just strikes me as wildly
inappropriate.
By being able to pull back
your original work and change
it in real time so that
the digital copy that gets released
on streaming services, which is the
way that most people now consume
music, is not just different,
but it seems like it's always been
that way.
It's basically creating a second
reality.
There's a sense now that maybe
nothing is permanent.
Art isn't going to be permanent
anymore, that it will
update itself in accordance with
contemporary sensibilities.
So if something in it becomes
offensive, well, we
don't have to reckon with that as an
artifact of an earlier time anymore.
It is insidious
that this is happening
in such a hidden way.
There's no bonfire of books.
If somebody like Beyoncé does not
take a stand on her right to create
as she pleases, there's very, very
little hope for anybody else,
including artists who are just
emerging, who are just developing
and trying to take risks but can't
or are too afraid to.